okay everybody i thought i'd give
a perspective on the new
echo loop ring from amazon
which is a very interesting
product that unfortunately is not well
executed
for the reasons i will explain in this
very short
and very first and possibly last ever
review on my channel
of a tech product but i am a geek i am a
nerd
i have millions of echo devices well not
millions of them but
alexa how many echoes do i have
i'm not sure okay good enough there's at
least one
in this room right now actually there's
about probably five in my house so i am
definitely an amazon
fanboy fan nerd i got this shirt from
amazon
i got this fake green screen behind me
from amazon
i get a lot of stuff from amazon and i
generally love their products but not
this one
and i'll explain why and what's wrong
with it in my perspective and how to
make it better
because i would love to get a fully
functional version
of this echo loop that meets all these
suggestions i'm going to put out in this
first and as i said probably
last given how bad i am at these things
so
the process is pretty cool if you're
invited
if you get an invitation coveted
invitation
to the one day or day one or whatever
they call it then you will be
eligible to request a free product from
amazon which is a ring
fit kit which comes to you basically
instantaneously
i think it was probably either 3d
printed or dropped by a drone
but i got it almost immediately after i
ordered
i was invited to participate in the one
day or day one whatever it's called
uh trial project of the echo loop
so it comes with a kit and you get your
choice of four different sizes
from small medium large to extra large
which is what i got it they say
recommend trying it on
your index finger which i thought was
really weird because i would never wear
a ring on my index finger and actually
you can access the functionality from
any finger
but even the extra large barely fits on
the index finger of yours truly
so i did put it on a ring finger
which was available and it has a button
that you're going to press when you
actually get the device
and that button is your activation so
as i said you try on the fit then you go
to amazon
you order it i believe it's about 140
dollars which is not
terribly expensive for a product that
has the potential that this device has
unfortunately as i say it doesn't really
live up to it and an apple watch is
far superior of course i have to have an
apple watch
both for uh functionality and for the
for the reason that
even once you get a working echo loop
you're not able to
connect to it by itself unlike the apple
watch which if you have a cellular plan
you can connect to
so um what you do is you have to pair it
with your phone
in my case it's an iphone and when you
do it
it has a lot of disadvantages you always
have to have your phone with you
kind of defeats the purpose it just
saves you from taking it out of your
pocket
but if you have an apple watch in
particular you already have a phone on
your wrist
and you can activate that using hey siri
or other
ways of activating your smart watch and
i'm sure there's an
analog for the google family of
products so once you choose your size
about
20 hours later you get a box in the mail
it looks like this
from amazon they're big brown trucks of
happiness
and you open it up it matches your size
xl and you see this incredibly cool
and very elegant packaging device that
they do
and there's your ring and it comes with
a little tiny button as i said
so that little button is what you press
to activate
the al word as we call it and it fits on
your ring finger and you can access it
from
your from your thumb on whichever hand
you put it on
when you press the button you were
supposed to activate
a tiny speaker and the tiny speaker
this has only been off charge which
points out one of the
uh one of the flaws in the product as
far as i'm concerned the battery life is
pitiful
i've had it last maybe six hours at a
time
using it once or twice an hour for a few
minutes
and so i'm gonna have to charge it this
is not staged i'm gonna have to charge
it again i just charged it yesterday
it's been sitting idle
uh so i'll charge it for a few minutes
i'll come back and resume
the review okay i'm back i haven't
actually started charging it yet
i wanted to show you this cool process
it does have some cool things that i
like
such as you can put it comes with this
handy little uh
holder that's magnetically activated so
you put it on and will start charging a
light will light up when you connect it
via usbc no micro usb
so you connect it via included micro usb
cable and it will start to charge and it
will glow green
actually pretty quickly you can start to
use it and um
but it's different than the apple
product it came dead on arrival the
battery didn't work in other words it
was functioning but it wasn't able to be
charged
so i'm going to charge it now give it a
few minutes and i'll come right back
okay we are back after about five minute
quick charge of the
echo loop and let's give it a try you
ready
excited to hear what it's all about what
all the buzz is about
uh here you go i'm going to push the
button that activates the smart
assistant with the name of a
what time is it
please try again let me try again
what time is it
what time is it so
it's asking me to please try again i
swear i had no
role in setting this up this is
happening about 50 of the time
the other 50 percent of the time it will
work and it'll do what it's advertised
to do
if you can hear it and if you can
actually put it in your mouth
so that it can hear what you're saying
i'll try that
what time is it
so you can barely hear it unless it's
right up to your ear kind of defeats the
purpose when you can just talk into your
watch pick up your phone
it does advertise all the things it can
do
some of the things to try in the
included instructions
say stay productive remind me to water
the plants when i get home
how late is the nearest whole paycheck
no whole foods open
what's on my to-do list remember that
dave wears a size 10
shoe i don't know who dave is but he's
got medium sized feet
stay connected you can actually make a
single contact in your phone
your top contacts when you press it you
will get connected by phone to that
person
through the ring and it will control um
you'll be able to play you know podcasts
and things on your iphone
just as you would normally but again it
kind of defeats the purpose you have to
take it out of your pocket
put it over here put it next to your ear
rather
and then hope that it makes the
connection which as i said it does about
you know
50 of the time if you're lucky i will
say a couple of the good things
about it i think it looks kind of cool
it is big
it's kind of you know my gangster pinky
ring is
a little bit smaller it's made out of
cool vibranium like material
which is great um the idea is is cool
and
of course it's it's very satisfying to
put it onto the
magnetic charger it locks in with a type
of
of force that's uh quite satisfying
oddly enough
um but the uh the bads really outweigh
the goods by a large margin in my
opinion
and the other thing that uh you know
there's some security flaws in this as
i'll point
out as we go on uh but first the bat
it's very laggy it only works a few you
know times out of
uh 10 when you try to use it uh it
doesn't connect to it
it's um you know in terms of fashion and
whatnot it is kind of kind of cool
but it is quite big um and you i find
myself snagging in on things
it comes with a list of warnings
including
a very uh gremlin-like warning against
water protection
the echo loop is water resistant you can
wash your hands
while wearing the ring but showering and
swimming
are not recommended note that water
resistance is not
water resistance is not a permanent
condition resistance might decrease as a
result of normal wear
i did wear this thing washed it did put
in the shower i don't know why it would
be more sensitive to
shower water than washing your hands as
we're supposed to do while singing
happy birthday in these crazy times uh
but uh but it's it's not waterproof so
you have to be careful about it
it says your finger changes uh size
throughout the day
and if removing your finger is
challenging your finger has expanded to
remove the ring
cut off your finger no you don't do that
you wash it with cold water so it gives
you some instructions to get it off
it is a little bit sticky the material
which i believe is titanium not
vibranium sadly
then there's other warnings do not use
when driving use caution
while driving at least engaging in
activity that requires your full
attention
so you know i guess to be totally safe
you would not be able to
to um you know to use it while you're
driving
um and so that's another consideration
to have you might want to take it off
when you're driving
um so all these things kind of make it a
little bit
uh premature as i say it's not ready for
prime
time get it prime amazon prime uh but
nevertheless i think it has potential
although i think they have to solve the
biggest possible security risk
of all and that's really the ugly and
the good bad and ugly
which is that you could actually have it
you know read your email
read a text message tell what's on your
schedule so anybody can just pick it up
and find it
and say oh i wonder what brian's you
know schedule is or wonder what's in a
shopping cart
there's some embarrassing things in
there it's not all amazon echoes
so um for these reasons i think they
have to address that either with some
kind of passcode or or some way
the apple watch does it through a
passcode when you first put it on
to me that's sort of uh unacceptable
that
anybody who would find it leave it lying
around can just find out what's in your
shopping cart
make a phone call to your top contact
and it will appear if your phone's
nearby it's coming from you
so i think it is has a significant flaw
in that the security presents a great
risk to it
i do think uh you know it might not turn
out to be the next fire phone
hopefully it will be updated and
upgraded they do have glasses that are
also out
i'll just tease you with them here they
are here no these are
these are reading glasses that i got
that i use sometimes at night
but to read very fine print in the dark
these are not the amazon glasses that
are supposedly coming out soon too i
believe they'll have the same
security flaw unless i'm wrong that they
can be activated without any passcodes
or what have you
so i think the idea is good in principle
it does need
significant risk mitigation before i'll
continue
to uh to use it and so i think it's uh
it's not ready for prime time as i say i
don't think you need to have it on hand
i also think it doesn't have the
features of the aura ring this is an
aura ring so you can tell which
which i didn't get on amazon with a few
things i did not buy on amazon
but the aura ring is is much smaller and
and the aura ring also does functions
that i think the
echo loops should do namely it should be
able to track your sleep track your
motion
track your steps etc and that would give
it real
uh viability to um for users to use
and actually have some other features
that are not built in
currently into the into the loop but are
easy enough at least for the aura folks
to implement in the aura ring which i
wear
to track sleep to trap track exercise
steps
i like to see them fight it out the
apple watch if it agrees with the aura
ring
they don't always agree but but you know
the ring is supposed to be the best
place to measure things like your
your heart rate much better than your
wrist so i think
i would would expect that amazon should
be able to make a pretty good competitor
to this
and it's not really proper to think of
the loop as a competitor to your smart
watch
so those are the good the bad and the
ugly features
of this uh smart wearable uh i don't
think it's ready
for prime time sorry to keep making the
same joke anyway your mileage may vary
some people love it i know some people
uh
you know are finding challenges with it
but i think until they fix the security
flaw
it's uh it's a pass for me so i will be
sending this back
making use of my amazon prime membership
to do so
so thanks a lot let me know what you
think about this in the comments if you
like
this review if you want to see more for
tech gadgets for nerds like me
and hopefully like you this is brian
keating
signing off and trying the echo loop one
last time
what time is it
the time is 407 pm